The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So a very
brief recap of where
we were in the last lecture.
We talked about electronic
band structure in crystals.
The lecture before we
said 1D, and we briefly
extended to 3D, now extension
just show you how 3D look like.
And then we start talking
about real crystals, a Bravais
lattice and crystal bonding,
how the crystal different
type of bonds,
when they is bond,
ionic bonding, covalent
bonding, metallic bonding.
And then we talk, at the
end we say reciprocal space,
how we represent
periodic 3D functions
and using the Fourier transform.
And for that, we need to
say the inverse of this
in 3D Fourier image is
in the reciprocal space.
So if we have a real
lattice, real space
lattice with a primitive
lattice vectors, a1, a2, a3,
we say we can--
the corresponding
reciprocal lattice vector
is a b1, b2, b3, where
b here, b1 is a2, a3.
And b2 you will just
permute the index.
So b2 is a3 cross a1.
So with that, you
can construct--
this is the primitive
lattice vector.
You can construct
array of points
using the reciprocal
lattice vector G.
And this is, let's
say, this is the way
you construct a
reciprocal space.
And correspondingly, you
have a primitive unit cell
in reciprocal space.
And also regional sites
cell, that's a unique way
construct a unit cell,
primitive unit cell.
And regular size
cell, there is also
not a le-- is this
smallest volume
is the first Brillouin zone.
And now, if you take a real
space last vector T, which
consists of an integer n1,
n2, n3, combination of a1,
a2, a3, and you take the
reciprocal lattice vector G.
And then you do the dot product.
And then you say, because
of the characteristics,
this is a volume
for the real space.
So because the characteristics
of this cross product,
you find out that G dot T is
just 2 pi times the integer.
So those are purely
the reciprocal space.
I was joking, it's really
mathematical concept.
It's a Fourier
transform of real space.
And so, I say, it turns
out, it's much easier,
like when we-- electrical
engineer always use frequency.
And physicists like
to represent areas
and in the reciprocal space.
And also, at the
end of last lecture,
I talked about the
Bragg condition.
I give you, if you have
a periodic structure,
you have a wave comes in.
And I have a
crystal, for example.
And the wave comes to.
It could be X-ray, it
could be an electron wave,
in transmission, electron
microscopy is electron wave,
and X-ray you have photon waves.
And you use a detector.
So a wave has a wave
vector k incident.
And let's say, this is the
final outgoing wave vector.
And it turns out, if you have
a periodic structure here,
crystal, and the condition
where you can detect--
this is you detector.
This is your source.
The condition you
can detect a signal
is when ki minus kf plus
or minus G equals 0.
So this is the Bragg condition.
And then we give this in--
by the end of last lecture,
and we went to Google image and
look at a lot of diffraction
patterns.
And for X-ray, we do 2 theta
measure the diffraction peaks.
So for me, I always say here
is where I struggle a lot,
whether I want to actually go
through the proof of the Bragg
condition or not.
And because it's a little bit
of mathematical intensive.
But I still want to do it.
And so, next I want to give you
mathematical proof of Bragg,
say, condition.
And it's conceptual
is not that difficult.
I have a wave comes in.
So I can represent the
wave in vector form.
So a plane wave, if you recall,
we gave the-- so whatever wave,
this could be an
X-ray, a photon wave,
it could be an electron wave.
So the wave is a wave vector ki.
And the direction, the
coordinate of this wave
I'm considering.
So I want to look at
a specific point r.
So if I take here, this
is my coordinate system.
And this is, from
here to here is my r.
And let's say this is my source.
So I write, this is my ri.
So the vector between this point
and the source is r minus ri.
That's from source to
the point in the crystal.
So this is the
distance, the direction
that the wave propagated.
So k times here, r minus ri.
So this is the
wave, a plane wave,
that traveling towards a
point r in the crystal.
If you say at this point
there is the atom there,
the X-ray comes in, the
atom can scatter the X-ray.
Same if it's an electron wave,
the atom there, the electron
interacts with the atom, and
the electron gets scattered.
So I will get scatter.
So I have, let's say, the
signal, the scatter signal,
of course, is going
all direction.
But I'm looking at my
detector is placed here.
So I want to look at the
scatter wave into this direction
into a direct detector.
And of course, say
this scatter depends
on the weight of the assay,
the atomic structure,
the electrons, neutrons
of the atom itself.
But I'm not going to care.
So I say, this is a scatter
amplitude of the scatter wave.
And I know it will be
proportional to the density
of the atom, meaning
the [? land ?] barrier.
If I have an atom there,
it gets scattered.
If I don't have an atom,
it doesn't get scattered.
So in the crystal, I have
a location for these atoms.
And the scatter wave
come back to my detector.
So let's say, this is r.
This is from here, you
say this is my vector rf.
So the distance traveled
between this signal
between the scatter point
and detector is rf minus r.
So this is the ikf
times rf minus r.
So this is-- nr is
at each r point.
But of course, when my signal
comes in, I have crystal,
I have many atoms.
So I have to--
the total detector signal is
integration of the each atom,
see how much a signal is
scattered to my detector.
So I will integrate.
I will integrate this signal.
This is the incoming,
this is scatter.
So it's, I will integrate over
the volume of the crystal.
This is what I get,
signal at the detector.
Again, I see some puzzle here.
This is a plane wave comes in.
This is a plane wave
scattered to the detector.
And this is where there,
I have an atom there.
And this is how many atoms
that I have in the crystal.
And now, this is a crystal.
So the arrangement of
the atoms is periodic.
So here, I say nr.
And in 1D, if it's a
periodic or Fourier function,
you know how to do
the Fourier series.
It's a sine, cosine.
And in 3D, the Fourier
expansion is nG.
This G is my reciprocal
lattice vector.
And sum up all those points.
And the exponential
minus ir times G.
So this is the expansion
of a periodic function
in reciprocal in the Fourier
space-- reciprocal space.
And you can prove it
if you do r plus T.
T is my periodic
function in real space.
Because this atom is
a periodical range.
And if I do G nG, I
substitute in the minus i.
r now is the r
times T times G. You
can say T times G is 2
pi times the integer.
Exponential 2 pi,
i 2 pi is what?
So if you do your math here,
this essentially is nr.
So that says my atoms is
periodically arranged.
That's why I say this
is the way I expand.
3D periodic function
in this case
is atomic location in the
reciprocal space, the Fourier
space.
So with this, now coming
back, this is a digression.
That's to say, my
nr, I can expand it
in G, in the sum
of G. I still have
to do the integration over the
volume for this r, different r,
different points in the atom.
So now I substitute this n
in terms of my expansion.
G is the sum.
So I have an
integration, volume,
and the sum over
G. I can invert,
I say I can exchange the order.
So if you follow my math,
what I will write next
is, I exchange the summation
after I expand n in terms of G.
And then I exchange the
summation with the integration.
So what I have is G.
And then say exponential,
so all those coefficients
are a times the s, I just
spaced it independent.
And I will have iki and ri.
This is a plus.
If I look at my
first exponent, these
are the relevant exponent,
because it's related
to position of detector.
So I have ikf times the rf.
Those I said, those
are irrelevant.
It's just a factor.
Depends on where you
put the detectors,
where you take your coordinate.
What's relevant
is now, as I said,
I switch that integration
with the summation.
I put the integration now here.
And what I really
have, because this is
the integration over r, volume.
So this term, I have ki times r.
This term I have kf times r.
Here I have r times G. It's
all exponential functions.
So now I have
exponential minus i, ki.
If you write all them
together, minus kf.
Here is a plus G
times the r, d volume.
So this is what matters here.
And what do you see here,
if you plot this function,
exponential function,
the i is sine cosine.
What happens when you
add the many-- you see,
this is a volume.
A typical crystal has 10
to 23 atoms, one more.
I'm just giving you that number.
If you sum many, many sine
cosine, what do you get?
I say, each one there
is a small difference.
The position has a
small difference.
Instead then, we vector--
we say the detector
with vector go
into detector, reciprocal
lattice, those are constant.
So if you sum many sine
functions, you get 0.
You get a 0 most of
the time, except when
this is itself is 0.
So the only way-- so if you put
a detector here, what it means,
if you put a detector
in order, if it's not
in the right position, you
don't measure any signal.
That's the diffraction.
That's why you see these spots
last time when we show the TEM.
So this one is, essentially,
the condition here
is this has to 0, and
that's my Bragg condition.
So this is a little bit
mathematical lengthy.
But the point I want
to say is, if you
see when we introduced
before the plane wave,
we said we can always represent
a wave by expanding it
into plane wave.
So this is a vector
plane wave representation
and scatter wave.
And using the periodicity
of the crystal,
any time you have
periodic structure
you can have a
diffraction effect.
And let's say if I have--
so this is a vector.
Now, I can give you
an example where
I have layers of atoms
in any specific direction
of the crystal.
I look at the, say, there is
periodic plans of the atoms.
And I put the X-ray coming
here at the angle theta.
And this is my incident
X-ray with vector.
And now, this is my 1D plot.
My periodicity is a.
So my wave vector, say
the reciprocal, in 1D,
reciprocal lattice vector is
in the periodicity direction.
Here I have 2 pi over a.
This Is 1D and times the n.
So now I write a
Bragg condition.
Because of the 1D, the vector,
the reciprocal lattice vector
is to power a in this direction.
So I do my component.
So what I have is the ki is 2
pi lambda i-- lambda incident
the photon
wavelength, let's say.
This is the incident
angle theta i.
So it's a sine theta i.
That's the vector component
in this direction.
And then my G is
So and I put my detector.
And X-ray is typically--
this is your source.
You put a detector
symmetrically on the other side.
So this will reflect the
angle equals incident angle.
So that's a two-theta scan.
You use the X-ray, people say,
what's your two-theta scan?
Rocking curve.
In that case, what you do is you
rock-- you rotate your crystal.
And different rotation crystal
you are rotating different
plan to meet the
Bragg condition.
And here, in the
reflected direction,
so you can see my wave
vector is going back.
So in the G direction,
I have a negative here.
So my-- is when I do, ki minus
kf is actually, I have again,
the reflected wave vector is a
sine theta i same as incident,
because I'm looking at the two
angle position, the detector,
symmetrically.
And then say, plus minus
G. So I can essentially
write that as 2 pi a times n.
So here, you can say,
I put them together.
I have sine theta i and
a and 2 equals n lambda.
So this is a--
when you put your
detector in typical X-ray,
you say incident reflection,
you put in, say, equal angle.
And when you measure
peak, you know the angle,
you know the
wavelengths, then you
go to determine
the lattice spacing
in that specific direction,
the lattice constant.
So that finishes our discussion
on the crystal structure
reciprocal lattice.
And now, let's move on.
So we talk about the electron.
The lecture we want to
talk is the atom vibration,
the phonons in crystal.
So the crystal, the electronic
structure in crystal.
So what we have next
is a lattice vibration
and the phonons.
So if you recall, we--
in the few lecture ago--
we say hydrogen
atom has a vibration
relative to each other.
And when we treat that
vibration, we use,
I say, spring to connect it.
So in general, the
entire atomic potential
is a repulsive attractive.
We talked in the last lecture.
And at the equilibrium point,
if you expand your potential,
because first order
derivative is 0,
so you will have 1/2 kx squared.
And with that, you say
your higher order terms.
But this acts as
the displacement
from the equilibrium here.
So the force, the nearest
order force is [? do, ?] dx,
and that gives me
a linear spring.
So when we deal with
the hydrogen atom,
a model, a hydrogen,
say, molecule.
A model is a mass
attached to spring.
And in that case, we now--
again, this is a confined wave.
A hydrogen molecule,
the vibration
is local to the hydrogen
molecule itself.
And the vibrational frequency
is k over M. It's a classic.
And also, the quantum, what
the quantum tells us is really
the energy cannot be any number,
it has to be rational M plus
1/2.
That's what we talked before.
And now, the question
is what about when
I have a chain of items
connected by springs?
So I'm looking at
a simple picture.
As we deal with the
electron, I have
one-dimensional atomic chain.
And in the case of electron, I
look at the potential Coulomb
interaction between the
electron and the nuclei.
But in the case of
the atomic vibration,
I'm looking at the force
interaction between the two
neighboring atoms.
And my model is the
simplest because I'm only
saying I connect the atom
only to the nearest neighbor.
In reality, if you think
about the ionic potential
we wrote before, one positive
ion, one negative ion.
You can have force it
Coulomb interaction.
But it could also
have a lesser--
negative ion or
positive ion could also
have direct force interaction.
So I could have a lot of spring
connect from here to here.
But I'm not doing that.
I'm only-- my
simplest model is only
connecting my nearest neighbor.
And now I want to
say-- find out,
what's the vibration or
energy of this atomic chain.
And I could go to write in
my quantum mechanical form
because if you recall, the
Schrodinger equation, what we
need is a potential constraint.
And that's what we
essentially said.
If you do a harmonic oscillator
in the hydrogen atom,
and you write your
potential, and then
we derive without solving
the Schrodinger equation,
that's my Bragg--
my own, say, way of solving
Schrodinger equation,
you have this vibrational
energy quantization.
If you recall that.
So what are we going to
do So if you do that way,
it turns out that your
vibrational frequency will
be the same as you
saw classically.
Essentially, this is same.
In the hydrogen molecule
case, this frequency
is a classical frequency
of any oscillator.
What we have here is
just energy quantization.
So because of that,
I'm just going
to solve Newton's second law.
I'm going to solve
it classically.
And say, gather the
frequency, and then
just introduce
you, similar to say
if you do quantum mechanically,
it's just at each frequency
your energy is quantized.
And so, it's two
different approach.
You get the same result.
And what are we going to look at
now is the atomic displacement.
So if I have an atom i here,
and the Ui is the displacement,
so is the xi.
xi is the coordinate minus xi 0.
That's the equilibrium
position there.
So this is just a
displacement of atom i.
And I'm going to write the
force, i plus 1, i minus 1.
So I have the force
equals the equal--
at equilibrium, that's
the minimum point.
So it's really the
relative difference
in the displacement gives
me the real stretching
or compression of the spring.
So when I write the
f equal Ma, and I'm
looking at the vibration.
Because there's
1D is constrained.
So I'm not looking at the
other plane vibration,
out of chain vibration.
I'm looking at the
in chain vibration.
So I'm going to write Mi--
M, the mass is the same,
because identical atoms.
So I have mass and the dUi.
So Ma, so dt square.
f equal Ma.
So this is my
[INAUDIBLE] say, Ma term.
And my force term is--
I'm looking at, this is the x
to the positive [INAUDIBLE]..
So this force is a
positive in this direction.
So I have a k, spring
constant Ui plus 1 minus Ui.
So that's the relative
displacement of the between i
plus 1 atom and i-th atom.
Minus this force, is if
it's i minus i minus 1.
So that's this direction.
So I have minus sign k
Ui minus U i minus 1.
So that's my f, the force
acting on the atom i, Ma.
So now I just need to solve
this simple discreet equation.
It's not a continuous
equation because there's
the atoms at a discrete point.
And if you solve a
continuous question,
you say, what's the
corresponding continuous form?
If I write this one
into k Ui plus 1
minus 2Ui plus Ui
minus 1, if you
do a finite atom, or finite
difference in analysis,
you know if you have a
continuous equation, that's
the second order derivative.
This will be the second--
if you discretize
a dU dx square,
you will get a form
like this, of course,
divided by delta x square.
So if you look at
this, if I write
continuous dt
squared dx squared,
that's a wave equation.
And wave equation,
if it's a, say,
again, the continuum limit,
my solution as a function of x
will be a wave equation, simple
solution omega t minus kx.
This will be the
continuum solution.
Now I'm just going to use this,
try to say whether I can--
my discrete solution will
still follow this form.
And in that case, xi--
so the positioning of xi,
this i-th atom, the x location
will be i times a.
That's xi.
And so, I'm just replacing x so
i plus y is i plus 1 times a.
And Ui, i plus a, and
going into the equation.
So my left-hand side
is the time derivative.
So Ui omega squared.
So what I have here
is M to second order
derivative with respect
to time gives me a.
And what I have here?
Mass i omega squared.
So it's mass omega squared.
And the exponential
mass i omega t minus k--
my location is a
little bit troublesome.
Let me write this as j,
because I don't want two i's.
OK, j.
And then say, I have
a k is my wave vector.
And x is i times a.
That's the left-hand side.
And the right-hand
side equals k.
And you can say,
my a will pull out.
And exponential here, I have in
common, is really x equals i.
Here is one less.
So what I have is 1
plus ik times a minus 2
plus exponential
minus ik times a.
That's here is one
less in coordinate.
And exponential
minus i omega t--
no, j times omega t minus kia.
I pull out a common factor among
i plus 1, i, and i minus 1.
That's my common
factor pulling out.
And the first one
I have i plus 1.
So it's an extra i to--
j.
j, sorry.
Extra j times a.
And here is one less deficient
because of Ui minus 1.
So it's a negative j times a.
And this is a j here.
Oh, i.
[LAUGHS] This is i.
Now I'm confused.
And so, you can say, this
one, these two factor cancel,
a cancel.
So I get a equation
for the eigenvalue
of the vibrational
frequency omega.
So this cancels, this
cancel, and a cancel.
What I have here is M omega
squared and a leg here.
And I have here k
and ejka plus 2--
plus e minus jka and minus 2.
ejk, e mink jk gives me cosine.
So 2 cosine ka, minus 2.
That's on the left-hand side.
I have another minus sign here.
So I put the 2 in the front.
So I have omega squared
equals k times n.
And 2k, because of that 2 I can
pull out, 1 minus cosine ka.
1 minus cosine ka is what?
Sine 2 times, right?
2 times sine 1/2 ka.
So I take the derivative--
take the square root.
So my omega then, the
vibrational frequency I
will take a positive.
So omega is 2k over
M. But then I have
to take a positive ka over 2.
So this is the
vibration frequency
of a one-dimensional
atomic chain.
And how does it look like?
It's a sine function,
essentially.
So when ka over 2 is
half pi is maximum.
So let's plot this.
So what we have here is really
the vibrational frequency.
This is ka.
So this is the frequency
of vibration omega.
And the ka-- so when ka
over 2 equals pi over 2,
that's the maximum.
That means k equals pi
over a, that's maximum.
So if I write this k, here
is a pi over a, the maximum,
and the sine.
And on the other
side, negative side
is, again, say,
negative pi over a.
And there's also sine function.
It's symmetric.
I didn't try to
draw this symmetric.
And of course, you can
extend to any k values.
So this is what the
mathematics tells us.
And now, let's think about
what does the physics tell us.
So first, we want to see
what's the value of k.
What's the value-- what are the
allowable values of k, the wave
vector?
And for that, again,
I can use two concepts
that I have been
talking for electrons.
One is a finite length of
whatever vibrational way
between the length
of the crystal.
And you do your
Fourier transform.
You do your Fourier expansion.
The other is the von Karman
periodic boundary condition.
And the two are
really equivalent.
So the von Karman periodic
boundary condition
say, the first
atoms here, and they
should equal to the
vibration of the n-th atom.
Say this is a na.
That's the length
of your crystal.
And with that, you use
the Bloch theorem, what
you have is a minus
k times na, that's n
is the total length
of our atoms equals 1.
That's what we used for
electron waves in 1D case.
And that means k times
na equals plus minus 2
pi plus minus 4 pi, all this.
So k then, if you divide it back
here, is a plus 2 pi over na
and 4 pi over na.
This continue.
So you if you count is,
again, when ka times
this is-- when error
it's really 2 pi here.
So before I say, between--
for electron between minus
pi to plus pi over a,
I have n points.
That's the case when I
have n atoms in the chain.
And that's the same.
If you do this, you will
find between minus pi
over a to plus pi over a, each
point of this k represent one
waveform, one, let's say, one
form of the wave in a crystal.
So if you go back to
quantum mechanics,
that's one quantum mechanical
state of this vibration.
So between miles pi over a plus
pi over a, I have n points.
So that's the k, what are the k.
And secondly, if you think
about in the case of electron,
because of symmetry, we do not--
we actually only draw between 0
to pi plus pi over a.
The negative side is symmetric.
And go beyond this,
it's repeating.
So in the case of
electron, because k is--
the other way to think
about k is 2 pi lambda.
That's the wavelength.
So for four long, in
fact, this waves really
doesn't mean anything new
even from the wave vector
perspective.
Because if you look at that,
I have lattice vibrations.
And the wavelengths, if
I have a k equals pi a,
what does that mean?
Lambda equals 2a.
In this point, my wavelength
is 2 atomic distance.
So that's my wave at this point.
Now, if I go to 2a, pi over 2--
oh, no.
2 pi over a, what's
my wavelength?
My wavelength will be this--
my wave.
This wave, there's no atom
moving at this location.
So you're part of a
minimum here, minimum here,
means [? less ?] [? than. ?]
So physically, in the case of
atom vibration for a lattice
wave, unlimited
between pi over a,
to plus pi over a-- negative
pi over a to plus pi over a.
And there are-- if
I have i-- n atoms,
I have n points between this,
say, first Brillouin zone.
So still the reciprocal lattice.
So this is the first point.
And now, I'm going to extend.
So here, I have what's simply
is 1D atomic chain, mono-atomic.
Every atom is the same.
So I'm going to extend this
picture for the vibration
or normal modes, the frequency.
And let's think
about diatomic chain.
Again, it's 1D.
Why I talk about diatomic?
If you recall in
the last lecture,
I say, in a silicon example,
silicon crystal, each lattice
point, I actually put
the two silicon atoms.
And sometimes I put
the three atoms.
So now, I have a crystal 1D.
This is, again,
my periodicity a.
But I could have another
atom, even identical,
or but it could be different.
Gallium arsenide
is another example.
Those are two different mass.
Even same mass, in the
silicon, one silicon
is closer here than here.
So I could have-- so my--
now let's say diatomic atom.
So this is one type.
And then I have another type
atoms here, two different mass.
And my period of
the crystal is a.
And I have one spring constant,
another spring constant.
It could be two different
spring constant.
So in one unit, say
I have two atoms.
So in that case, you can go back
again, write the f equals Ma.
But you have to write
to set of equation.
Each set is for one
specific type of atom.
And these two sets, of
course, are coupled.
So what do you have--
I'm not going to write it down--
but the solution, what the
solution will look like is,
again, I'm writing my first
point on [? zone ?] pi over a.
This is a k.
And this is a omega.
And we have still
the bottom solution,
we draw sine function.
But I get the extra
range because I
have two atoms per unit cell.
So they are-- what this
two branch mean is they--
in this branch, a
more intuitive picture
is the vibration
is all in harmony.
So when this one
atom vibrate here,
this atom vibrate here, this
one is here, this one is here.
That's the lower
frequency branch.
And now, the other, the
higher frequency branch,
same wave vector.
So I don't plot my different
wavelengths in that case.
So this atom is vibrating up.
This-- so it's the opposite.
So this atom now going here.
And this atom going here.
So it's, say, one
is sort of in face.
The lower frequency
one is all the atoms,
two types are in face.
The other one is
more out of face.
And out of face is
higher frequency.
And in face one lower frequency.
And this is also as
we extend the phonon,
h nu is the
vibration, the alpha--
the vibration quanta
[? h nu ?] is a phonon.
So higher frequency one
has a higher energy.
So when the-- so that's the
two different vibration here.
This is an acoustic mode.
And this is the optical mode.
And so, later on as
we add the phonon,
so this is acoustic
branch, acoustic phonons,
optical phonons.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
reason for those names?
PROFESSOR: Well, the-- so
optical is when you have
a light--
some of the light, because
of higher frequency,
so infrared light, for
example, could interact easier.
You have to have the--
when you have the photon
interact with the atom, the
energy has to match again.
So glass, SiO2, the glass, why
you have a greenhouse effect?
Because the
vibrational frequency
is about 10 microns and the
light immediate in this room
is about 10 micron.
And light hit the window and get
resonant between photon energy.
And then, as the vibration
there, it's get absorbed.
So the energy doesn't escape.
That's your greenhouse effect.
So now we have acoustic
branch, optical branch.
I'm going to pile more onto it.
It's a 1D.
So in the model I have,
the vibration direction
is the same as the wave
propagation direction.
What is that way?
Longitudinal, right?
That's the sound wave you hear.
Sound wave is a
longitudinal wave.
But if I relax to say, this
atom can also vibrate out
of this chain direction--
AUDIENCE: Transverse.
PROFESSOR: I got the other
motion, transverse motion.
Do you think it's easier to do
this way, longitudinal motion,
or it's transverse?
AUDIENCE: Transverse?
PROFESSOR: Transverse?
AUDIENCE: Easier explaining.
PROFESSOR: So in
terms of the mode.
So well, this is a software.
So a chain, if you
say, atoms there,
is it easier to vibrate this
way or vibrate this way, 1D?
A chain is probably,
if you think
about one-dimensional atomic
chain, it likes to fold.
That's a transverse direction.
It's a lower energy.
So now, if I do
transverse, I got that--
I can decompose the transverse
in two perpendicular direction.
So in general, so if
I relax to 3D motion,
I only do allow,
say 0 to pi over a.
But remember, their
symmetry [INAUDIBLE]
is the same direction.
So what I have,
this is longitudinal
and this is transverse.
And the other comment is either
the zone center, the boundary
here, it's my maximum.
So this gradient here is 0.
Typical vibration-- those save
energy or frequency dispersion
relation at the boundary
is perpendicular.
So here I have a
longitudinal acoustic branch.
I have transverse
acoustic branch.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is
there two [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Why is there two
transverse [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Well, so, this is
the wave propagation direction.
If the vibration is this
direction, that's one.
Vibration into this
direction, that's the other.
AUDIENCE: So why
is it different?
PROFESSOR: If it's a 1D
chain, it doesn't differ.
But in 3D crystal, in
one direction vibrate
and the other
perpendicular direction
they may not see the
right environment.
But see, you're
right, in many cases,
they actually
degenerated if the two--
if you look at two perpendicular
direction, they are the same.
So you actually see one line.
But they actually
imply there are
two branch that's degenerate.
Remember, the degeneracy.
I'll come back to
that degeneracy again,
say, after we discuss all of
this dispersion relations.
So this is acoustic.
So here I have optical
three branches.
See, again, transverse
longitudinal branches.
And so, that's the going from
1D mono-atomic, diatomic, to 3D.
And of course, this
is 3D in the sense
that I still consider one
wave vector direction.
Now you go to a crystal
in different direction.
You plot a different
sets of curves.
And so, here, one more.
If I have m atoms.
So here is a diatomic.
So if I have m atoms, per basis.
So the lowest three, so I have--
and I have n points,
lattice points,
so now you do your counting.
See, I have 3n acoustic branch.
So the lowest of the
branch is acoustic--
acoustic modes, not the branch.
Three acoustic modes.
Because here, if you turn
negative pi over a to plus pi
over a, I have n point.
I have three branch.
That's three n.
And then, I have the rest is 3m
minus 1 times n optical modes.
So optical modes, the more
atoms you have per unit--
per lattice point, the more
optical modes you have.
Now, this is all continuum
mechanics, or not
continuum mechanics,
it could be,
but it's a classical
mechanics, f equal Ma.
But it could be atoms.
So it's a discrete but
the classical mechanics.
Now, what the quantum add is
like what I commented before.
The energy at each mode
can not be continuous.
And normally, vibration
energy is a kinetic energy
plus potential energy.
You add, that could be
a continuous function.
And what quantum tells you,
at each mode, each frequency
or each mode, and the frequency,
the energy of that mode
is 1/2--
say, h nu times, say, times--
n plus 1/2.
And again, this 1/2 is,
say, 0 point energy.
Zero point energy is
actually a requirement
of the uncertainty principle.
Because here, when
we draw, I can say
the atom is exactly is here.
If it's exactly here,
its location is fixed.
And Heisenberg
uncertainty principle
will say its momentum
is expanded to infinite.
So because of that, this say
there is always this 1/2 h
nu that's the 0 point energy.
And there is, in fact, some
connection of this to the force
interaction between it's
one-- it's the fundamental--
it's a van der Waals force is
equivalent to this zero point
energy.
There are some
interesting connections.
So that's the-- this
is what the quantum.
If you solve your Schrodinger
equation with the potential,
harmonic potential, and
you get all the dispersion
same as a classical.
But you get the energy context.
We didn't take that approach.
So this quantile h nu,
that basic energy quantile
is a phonon, same as
the energy quantile h
nu for electromagnetic
wave is a photon.
It's not an electron
like an electron.
So phonon, photon are bosons.
And the spin is an integer spin.
Electron is a 1/2 spin.
And electron obey the
power exclusion principle.
So each quantum state can
only have maximum electron.
But each quantum state, here,
this k for specific k value
represents the wave function,
a vibrational wave function,
that's quantum state.
Each quantum state can have n--
could be 0, 1, to
infinite of phonons.
So those are bosons.
And it's fundamentally
different.
And it doesn't have a rest mass.
Electron has a mass.
What's a mass of photon?
There's no rest mass, photon.
It has a momentum.
It has an energy.
So you look, either you
can create the pressure
but doesn't have a mass.
It's a collective vibration,
it's collective modes.
So I joked.
I had once a colleague say
after he sit in my class,
I still don't know
what is a photon--
a phonon.
And it's a fictitious
particle sometimes people say.
It's not a real particle.
It's a-- so this is a phonon.
It has an energy and
it has momentum hk.
And in 3D, it's k.
Or energy sometimes we
write as h bar omega.
Your h nu, depends on
whether you use nu or omega.
So that's the phonons.
And now you go to, like I
said, you go to real crystal,
you will see different phonon--
different direction have
a different dispersion.
So again, I will go
to Google and to show
you those complexity
in real crystals.
But before we do that, let me
introduce some approximation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How far
out of equilibrium
would you have to be so that
your original approximation
that is just a harmonic
oscillator doesn't [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: My original
harmonic oscillator--
so a very good question.
I remember, for example,
I just mentioned glass.
It turns out that--
I also mentioned
the hydrogen atom.
And turns out that in physics,
when people talk of phonon,
they talk about
the extended modes.
So hydrogen atom
vibration, people
mostly do not call it a phonon.
And once I went to
a phonon conference.
And I ask, say, a very
famous guy, I say,
what about the phonons in glass?
Because the glass is not a
periodic, it's not a crystal.
And oh, nobody knows, he said.
But still have those modes.
And but see, you ask, there
is an even more profound, say,
question one could
ask in this direction.
Because when you
go to a third term,
here a potential is a
harmonic, second term.
Go to a third term,
that's the scattering.
That's the two phonons
start to couple.
And this is, in fact,
very different for light.
Light normally hard to
couple to each other.
But phonon, you easily
couple to each other
because of this third term.
But if that third
term is so strong,
and it can come back to
affect your dispersion.
And there's-- I do not
know good ways to do it.
But there are people
publishing paper, for example,
recently there was a
paper on the soft phonon
in [? Telluride. ?] And because
of the strong enharmonic
interaction, that changed a
lot on the phonon dispersion.
Then the question is, if the
phonon scattering is so strong,
you break the wave.
I say, this basic picture
is I have extended waves
through the whole crystal.
But say if it
breaks the wave, it
doesn't say if the
universe of this frequency
is to give you [INAUDIBLE] time
for one period of vibration.
But if they-- you went
to break this, say,
wave is even faster
than the one period,
then I don't see how people--
I do not know how people
are describing those.
Let's see.
The next is the approximation.
If you recall for electrons,
we say at the bottom,
we use a parabolic.
We say at the bottom in
this region, the first order
dispersion, the first
order derivative is 0.
And so, I use a parabola
to represent electrons.
And for phonons, for optical
phonon and acoustic phonon,
you look at it.
It's like a sine function.
And then, the
simplest approximation
that people have made, one is
a linear function rather than
the sine function.
And this is a--
the order is flat.
That's more appropriate
for optical phonon,
and this is more appropriate
for acoustic phonon.
And this approximation
is Debye approximation.
And this is the Einstein.
It turns out that Einstein
first created this model for
to model the specific
heat of a crystal.
But say, it's not valid.
See, it doesn't agree
with the experiment
when we go to very
low temperature.
That's because when you
go very low temperature,
most phonons are here.
And so, the specific
measurement doesn't agree.
So Debye introduced
the linear dispersion.
So those are two
different dispersion.
And the corresponding frequency,
this is the Einstein frequency,
and this is the Debye frequency.
And in a real
crystal, Debye model,
very often we will do the--
later on when we're talking
specific heat-- people
typically use Debye model.
And this k, of course,
I only draw 1D.
But in real crystal is different
direction, have different k.
But Debye model actually
is a isotropic crystal.
So it approximate not only
linear in one direction,
just to use one direction
represent the whole crystal.
So that's-- with that, there are
some relations in terms of what
you convert, what's the
corresponding Debye lattice
constant here.
You have to count the total
modes to be consistent.
So where we are going from
here is in the next lecture,
I'll continue to come back
to, say, use this simplest
approximation, Debye
model, Einstein
model, to count degeneracy.
Before, when we
talk about the, say,
hydrogen atom, electrons, we
say degeneracy is 2n square.
That's how you understand
periodic table.
But now, if you
look at this, if I
draw in one crystallographic
direction, this is pi over a.
And in another direction there
could be another dispersion.
So this represents
a different mode.
But they could have
the same frequency.
So that same frequency
means the same energy.
And I can have many modes
that have the same energy.
And I have to count
that degeneracy.
And that counting
is very important
if you want to do
any calculation.
It's a mathematical concept.
That's a density of states.
We're going from degeneracy
to density of states.
And that we'll do
in the next lecture.
So I want to use
the rest of today,
let's go to do our exercise,
see what we have learned.
So I want to do a few things.
First I'll continue to look
at the 3D phonon dispersion.
It means that we're taking
of very simple models.
But when you read any
paper, it looks like there's
a lot of curves inside.
You will say, it's just a plot
in different crystallographic
directions.
And we'll also then go
to look at the relevance.
Let's look at some papers.
So first thing, I'm
going to use my desktop.
So let's first look at--
that's my last homework.
And I have trouble.
Let's do this.
Google-- I have a little bit
trouble using this different
way of putting the sidebar--
Google image.
And I want to look at the phonon
silicon phonon dispersion.
So now you look at a silicon.
This is a, when they say
qqq, that's 1,1,1 direction.
And this is a 0,1,1 and 1,0,0.
So since silicon is
a cube, y1 direction
is diagonal direction.
1,0,0 is the any of the
main edge direction.
1,0,0 is the--
0,1,1 is if you
think about a plane--
let's see.
This is your 1,0,0 direction.
And this is a plane
for 0,1,1 direction.
And here is the diagonal
is 1,1,1 direction.
So you can see here,
in 1,0,0 direction,
the two transverse phonons
degenerate into one,
in the longitudinal phonon.
And here, you have
optical phonons.
But see, in the 1,0,0 direction,
you don't have that degeneracy.
So you have two transverse,
one longitudinal
and in the optical.
And let's go look at
the silicon electronic.
Silicone band structure.
Here.
Again, so now you have to
say, this is a gamma to l.
That's the gamma to x, is 1--
I think that's the
1,1,1 direction.
And 1,0,0 direction.
And this is where the top-most--
if you do 0 temperature, this
is the electron-- uppermost
electron, the Fermi level.
So this is a valence band.
Those are the valence bands.
Here is a conduction band.
That's the lowest.
You see, that's an absolute gap.
Between here and
here is the minimum.
That's the band gap.
And it's an indirect,
the minimum and maximum
not at the same point.
So a photon comes
in, if you want
to lift the electron
from here to here,
that's the absorption process.
It doesn't have enough momentum
because there-- between here
and here is a big k.
hk is the momentum.
A photon momentum is very small.
So it's harder for photon
to be absorbed in silicon.
And if you look at the
electron for gallium arsenide--
gallium arsenide band structure.
And maybe this one.
You see, the minimum--
that's not-- this
is not-- nitride.
Gallium nitride.
So let's look at--
this is not all directions.
This is just a
drawing 1,1,1, 1,0,0.
But the minimum and maximum,
this valence band, conduction
band, is at the same k vector.
That's a direct
gap semiconductor.
See, there you actually have--
you see that here there
are different bands.
These are the hole--
valence band holes.
And different bands
have different mass--
effective mass.
This is lighter,
this is heavier mass.
We talked, say, effective
mass, when you do, say,
the parabolic approximation.
Now let's look at the papers.
I saw that still the best way--
I was checking where--
which journals.
We don't know much yet.
So let's still go back to
Applied Physics Letters.
Applied Physics Letters is a--
what's the recent issue?
[INAUDIBLE]
Photonics optical.
So now, if you look
at first paper,
Non-equilibrium longitudinal
and transfer optic phonons
in terahertz quantum
cascade lasers.
Pretty timely.
So what does it mean?
I didn't read the paper.
I look at title.
I did look at the title.
So what does it mean?
My guess-- I would
just say, sometimes
I go there and take
a look and say,
I can guess what the paper
might be talking about.
And a quantum cascade laser is--
a typically laser is you
have a conduction band,
you have a valence band.
And you put the electrons.
So you actually put a current--
semiconductor, you put
a current into here.
You put a lot of electrons
from an external injection.
You put a lot of holes to here.
And now, electron will
fall from here to here
and give off a photon.
That's the emission process.
Of course, laser is
stimulating emission.
And this is a typical
semiconductor laser.
A quantum cascade laser is
you use that-- let's say,
this is a conduction band.
And typically, we just
look at gallium arsenide.
But when you make that
gallium arsenide very thin,
we have a quantum well.
We talk about the quantum well.
So this is in 3D.
Now, when you are one direction,
you make it very thin.
So the energies start to
discretize in that direction.
So my wave vector space then
becomes very large, basically.
And so, it doesn't use the
electron to hold recombination
to generate photon.
It actually use energy
level in quantum
well going from electron to
electron to generate photon.
And the cascade down, the
next quantum well is the same.
So the photon stimulate,
emit another photon.
So that's a quantum
cascade laser.
But say, what it must be is,
say, in the emission process
you have light.
You have, say, electron,
you have phonon.
So some of the electron will
interact with the phonon,
with the lattice vibration.
And in this process, when we
go to-- let's take a look.
So you could dump a lot
of energy to after phonon.
And after phonon-- and
if they can scatter
with acoustic phonon,
they will become, say,
at a different
temperature, drive out
of equilibrium from
the acoustic phonons.
So different modes they
will have long equilibrium.
Let's see, what
does this paper say?
People experiment on [INAUDIBLE]
equilibrium and longitudinal
phonon, and the interface
transfers like optical phonon,
associated with the
electron transport
in resonant phonon terahertz
quantum [? cascade ?] lasers.
So how they-- this is the
energy levels in quantum well.
See, this is the one quantum
well, different quantum well.
And the wave functions, or
I say, in each quantum well.
And this is the, let's
say, optical phonon.
So it must be-- this
is probably the power.
I don't know whether it
is electrical power or--
but looks like it's the Raman.
So after experimental
longitudinal method--
structure to be
measured phonon--
you see, they must be
using Raman to measure--
see, this is a
laser [INAUDIBLE]..
So what are Raman process?
A Raman process is
when you have phonon--
you have crystal.
You have a laser comes in.
And now, the light of the
laser, you have energy h nu.
Now, the phonon
energy is very small.
It's a milli--
I say, rather 10 to 20
milli-electron volts.
Argon laser is about 0.5 micron.
So it's about 2.5
electron volts.
So but this light can
interact, say, with the phonon
and then shift the--
the scattered light, the
frequency could be shifted.
So this is a, say, plus or
minus h bar omega of the phonon.
So with that, you can measure
the phonon equivalent, say,
population by looking
at its temperature, all
this sorts of stuff.
And so, that's an
example of phonons.
And I'm sure I
think I should stop.
But if you look at
it, there are actually
quite a few papers in
this issue journal,
and the next few paper
also I saw phonon topics.
All right.
OK, stop here.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]